at eight in the morning is the
earthquake
and then
8 15 we already in the hotel
and 8 20 we arrive here i park my zip
somewhere across the street
and start to filming
i'm trying to like filming from outside
because i see
this uh gate is really nice i'm just
trying to pointing and framing
i can i am
i'm filming the minaret take a foot test
about that take a picture
um you know like is you know simple uh
cameraman things try to having uh
something from that time
and then
while i'm filming i can hear my wife
yelling from from far you know across
the street that
tell me that dandy come on we need to go
because the water coming to town cup
water all the people tell me that all
you know the water's coming to the town
i'm just like i'm still not really care
about that because i remember the last
float the big float we
we have in bandar ate like maybe just
like not really you know maybe a meter
or something he's like doesn't recognize
doesn't
understand about what happened
and then i'm just oh come on easy i keep
filming
and after that i can see the water
like maybe the first water i see coming
from behind uh
grandmas
it's about it's around maybe
five six meters water
coming to
that way
and i'm still
what
what is it you know something like
like you're freezing because of
something you know like i'm
what is it
and then after that there's the building
like a
three floor building something
so the first water is coming like
this i'm still like
what
what i can do you know how come i'm just
like still not believing what what
happened
and then when the water just like i'm
coming from behind the building like
this like around 10 meters something
it's like okay
i need to go from here
so i run and jump to my jeep my wife is
already stand by there and some of the
people is already like i'm trying to go
with me with my jeep so everybody like
jump to my jeep and i can
i can remember that maybe more than 20
people in my gym all that time because
it's actually open cup you know it's
open jeep and long sizes so i can like
carry a lot of people in my jeep
and then
we
again it's miracle all that time because
usually i need to like more more than
three times to start the engine
and on that time it's just once and then
in the middle of the street i can't see
the
blind woman you know like poor woman who
asking money from people around the
street
i can see one of them blind and really
like look like a really confused and you
know like
um
like doesn't know what to do you know
and i'm just telling and asking the
people who already in my gym please grab
that mom for uh you know
we can bring them you know
what i'm thinking of that time even not
blind people like looks like really
really scared about what happened
and what what what happened to the blind
woman so and nobody wants to help them
so i just tell them okay you have no
driver i'll jump out from the car and
then grab them first
uh you know bring to my jeep
and then start uh drive again so what i
remember my car is the last car who can
survive from this area because
everybody's like the other car already
like swapped by the water and then
and lucky me because i took the time to
to grab the blind woman
i don't know how but i can find my mom
somewhere in the middle of the street
with my younger younger brother
and i'm just like oh my god it's really
like a really
right time for me to
to go on that time but it's kind of like
surrounding by the beach so beach is
kind of like a really my life you know
but after that things i think i need
like more than a years maybe to going
back and
actually i'm going to the beach and
yelling
as loud as i can on that time
i'm not scared anymore i'm
tsunami will not come anymore you know
like like try to tell to myself that
you're okay
i'm just i'm still a little bit shaky
when i'm arrived at that beach
and um
yeah it's a bit like i'm really confused
about the thing because i lost like a 50
member of my family like um
and even i can't find a dead body or
i'm just thinking of that time like
all of my family member like going to
make her
in one big group and never come back